the purpose of an education degree was
to get competence in the idea of
instruction and in any good one to also
have a particular discipline or two in
which you really learn the discipline so
that you could pass it on
when did these external things these uh
must you now show by the way that you're
in favor of carbon tax if you're going
to be a teacher there's no difference
where did the teacher's profession and
the teachers unions which are strong in
every other way where are they looking
back at these
anti-racist experts and saying who are
you to change the professional idea and
the professional qualifications of
certified teachers and where are the
teachers themselves if teachers have
value it is that they seek truth that
they give to their students they
appetite for truth that they do not
submit to forced ideas and
indoctrination
[Music]
foreign
I'm here today again with Mr Rex Murphy
one of Canada's preeminent journalists
and we're going to talk today about a
piece of legislation that is through
second reading in the Ontario
legislature
Bill 67 which is known as the racial
equity in the education system Act
and I've made a couple of videos and Rex
has now written a column about this
particular piece of legislation some
other people like Barbara K have been
trying to draw attention to it and so
we're going to talk today a little bit
more about it and go into it in more
detail and
try to alert Canadians to why how they
should think about the bill perhaps and
why they might be concerned about it if
they're inclined to be concerned about
such things so Rex maybe I'll let you
start and and then maybe we can address
some of the specifics of the bill well
well to begin with the build 67 as in
your previous uh two podcast your own
individual one and and then the group
uh you do you do point out the very
obvious thing
uh that you're introducing into the
entire educational system of of a
province
what is an ideology there's no need to
walk around these words
and and it also in my mind shows a
continuation
of a perversion a twisting away from its
normal course a perversion of what the
idea of education is
it seems now that in every possible
social justice or critical racist or
transgender whatever the cause is
the schools of North America but now
we're going to get to Ontario
specifically the schools of North
America have decided to make themselves
centers of social attitude formation
the purpose of education is to open the
mind
it is to bring a mind into its capacity
it is to treat a mind to learn from
itself
and it is always to be
fundamentally the inculcation of the
absolute necessary skills for a man or a
woman a boy or a girl to function in the
society
computation
literacy history one very general point
I want to make at the very beginning of
this chat
is that the schools have forgotten what
they are
and instead of building these
competencies and establishing character
over time through the disciplines of
understood instruction
they they rent themselves out to the
cause of the moment and worse than that
in the case of critical race theory in
particular and this new bill in Ontario
that they put had adhesion tape on
themselves and they make the exterior or
ulterior possibilities of Education we
shouldn't be racist the absolute core of
their function and being let me give you
a parallel when I was at CBC about eight
or nine years ago in CBC for the benefit
of audience outside of Canada is a
television and radio Communication
Service it's a national broadcast
service and its main concern
is first the news and then the idea of
the nation however in CBC and it was
established in written policy it was put
out to all radio and all television
programs that our number one objective
our number one objective
is diversity
now if you're a broadcaster your number
one objective is broadcasting and if
you're a school
if you're a school this is almost holy
it's vocational for sure your number one
objective is to build a character in
mind of the students Within by
discipline instruction in understood
courses and nothing to do with
pre-planted and in this particular case
divisive and pernicious ideologies so
why the Ontario government of Doug Ford
which is conservative has latched on to
an American inspired ideological and
hard left movement and made it the
central dynamic
of the entire educational Network I've
watched your videos
this is this is this is insane and when
parents learn that their schools are no
longer making their their lives better
through better reading and better
teaching by the way whenever has a
school board in Ontario put in one of
those wonderful bulletins
advising them oh how much do our
students have tuned into poetry how much
our students are now really alive with
the spirit of mathematics no it's all
environment it's racism it's identity
politics it's sexual politics they have
every agenda
but the agenda that only a school should
have that's my overview well one of the
things I would say about that is that
the ideals of Education that you just
espoused so the development of
individual capacity for literature
literacy and numeracy and an
appreciation of History are all
predicated on the idea that the purpose
of the school is to develop sovereign
individual citizens and exactly what
people need to understand about the
ideology that underlies this bill is
that none of that is accepted as valid
yeah in the within the confidence of
that ideology so people are best
conceptualized and only ethically
conceptualized as members of groups and
racial groups particularly for this bill
but the other group identities are not
lurking far behind and are equally valid
and the entire purpose of the education
system is to teach people that group
identity is Paramount and that moral
people do nothing but strive to reduce
all perceived inequalities between all
perceived groups and so it's
fundamentally anti-individualist and so
the people and I don't believe this is
an overstatement
the people who wrote that bill would
regard your view of Education as racist
because it doesn't give racial
categories uh epistemological
philosophical priority
and so we might take a look at some of
the details of the bill because the
details matter and so for example we
could say
if you're racist so this is
the part of the bill that deals with one
subsection one one
racism
means the use of socially constructed
ideas of race and so you have to accept
that to begin with that there's an
attempt there to insist that the
theories of social constructionism are
going to be Paramount uh we can get to
that later to justify or support whether
consciously or unconsciously
subconsciously the notion that one race
is superior to another okay so we could
focus just on that which is like one one
hundredth of the bill so now
if I believe that you're subconsciously
racist
then that constitutes
well that's the question what does that
constitute something to be worked
against now you're racist if you're
subconsciously racist now the question
is well what does it mean to be
subconsciously racist and then the next
question is well who gets to decide if
you're subconsciously racist and what
does that mean
and so if you believe for example that
Canada has strived mightily in its past
in its flawed manner to promote a
society where people have equality of
opportunity somewhat independently of
their group categories if I believe that
explicitly or if that shapes my
perceptions does that now mean that I'm
racist and I would say according to the
dictates of this bill it certainly does
mean that
well there are so many contradictions
involved in the pseudo now this is not a
philosophy it's an ideology it's a it is
to use their own word a construct for
political and social advantage and we
have a whole lot of them which you'll
probably get into later but let's go to
a couple of those points that you made I
heard and this is I have a good memory I
heard this as long ago as 1985.
it stuck in my mind for various reasons
it was a very very popular CBC show and
the biggest host of the time and
probably the biggest host of a radio
program ever that was Peter zowski and
funny thing that's almost 40 years ago
that he was being interviewed by some
race expert at the time
and Peter's asking because he was always
that kind of you know contempt to
developing extremely liberal person he
asked the questions and this is why you
reminded me of it how can I know
he was accepting the theory by the way
how could I know that I'm unconscious
can I be unconsciously racist
well you're just drawing out everything
you throw out the the moral decision you
you throw out the determination not to
look at other people and judge them on
exterior or exstringent characteristics
you empty the whole moral idea of of a
Martin Luther King and his famous famous
phrase content of the character not
color of their skin you also this is
this is amazing that an educational
institution a school board or a
department of education could allow this
slippery concept of unconscious bias
which by definition is ineffable is
unreachable is untestable if you don't
know you're unconscious bias
unconsciously biased how in the hell
does someone else looking at you
forgetting your external characteristics
and your external actions determine oh
on the basis of my
scaffolding of a philosophy I know you
are and then you could turn the question
around I often wonder about these
wonderful anti-bias trainings that
teachers and and poor people in
corporations in the CBC in particular
drag their their employees off to
anti-bias I always want to know if the
person up on the front of the of the
class of that kind how did we know that
she's not biased if she's gonna peddle
this this tribe Garden Jordan it really
is when do we get so childish that we
accept these things
those explicit training programs too by
definition can't address implicit bias
because the only way you can address
implicit biases by mass practice and
repetitive training and so even by the
dictates of the theory itself the
proposed mechanism of of uh remediation
is impossible so here's another Clause
from the from the bill
if in the opinion of the minister a
report submitted under subsection one
indicates that the board's new teacher
induction program does not include
anti-racism and racial Equity training
the minister shall inform the board of
that fact and shall direct the board to
further develop its anti-racism
accountability program and so what this
means essentially is that all new
teachers are going to be required to
accept the doctrines of anti-racism this
anti-racism movement let's say and
that's not the same as non-racism right
no it's not so the idea that uh that
that that that uh your your non-racist
for example if you don't if you strive
not to let a prior judgments about skin
color for example you treat everyone the
same that's not good enough even your
intent to treat it's not good enough you
have to be an activist in the
anti-racism training movement to be a
qualified teacher or the minister has to
take action and it means you have to
accept the equity Doctrine which is that
all differences in outcome are a
consequence of systemic racism right
system-wide and that if you don't accept
that well then you're also racist and so
I should point out that this Doctrine is
so extreme that moderate leftists in the
U.S rejected out of hand
very very last Point that's also
extremely interesting in the politics of
Canada uh you've had revolts at school
award you've had school board members
topped out because under either under
surreptitiously or silently they
slightly brought anti-racism critical
race Theory into every aspect of the
curriculum and when the parents started
seeing some of these bulletins or the
word came out they went to the school
board luden is the most famous example
and said what in the hell are you doing
in fact one parent got arrested for
protesting some of the books that these
were passing out to kindergarten to
grade five on various sexual and exotic
practices that's his first thing the
second thing is the authoritarian nature
of this you've all you just mentioned
that teachers have to demonstrate they
have to display have to have to prove by
our standards by our arbitrary and
unfounded assertions that you are not in
coincidence with our range of thought
well I took an education course a long
while ago and the purpose of an
education degree was to get competence
in the idea of instruction and in any
good one to also have a particular
discipline or two in which you really
learn the discipline so that you could
pass it on
when did these external things these
must you now show by the way that you're
in favor of carbon tax if you're going
to be a teacher there's no difference
where did the teacher's Perfection and
the teachers unions which are strong in
every other way where are they looking
back at these anti-racist experts and
saying who are you to change the
professional idea and a professional
qualifications of certified teachers and
where are the teachers themselves if the
teachers have value it is that they seek
truth that they give to their students
they appetite for truth that they do not
submit to forced ideas and
indoctrination and if if you're educated
and that's what a teacher is then he or
she looks at this particular thing and
say oh why if you say the cause is good
then we can do anything we can change
the thing we can enter every aspect of
this curriculum we could we can impose
on you that you have this set of ideas
Jordan I'm serious I really am I do not
know
how we've become so complacent complicit
how we accept second rate so-called
theories hard left politics pushing in
to every domain of cardinal Civil Life
and here we have it in Ontario because
it's a scandal if you want to call
yourself a conservative government I
don't care if you are or not but if you
call yourself conservative why are you
embracing one of the Wilder theories now
getting completely trashed in the
country where it began I.E the United
States this is bizarre
well so here's another one
the government's now required to
establish and provide
annual professional development programs
to educate teachers and other staff of
the board about promoting racial equity
and developing the necessary tools to
address racism so those are ongoing
indoctrination sessions to provide
programs Etc or other supports for
students Etc who've been targeted by
racism so and then worse to establish a
protocol for recognizing acknowledging
tracking measuring investigating and
responding to incidents of racism
reported by students teachers staff
parents or the school community and so
what all you have to do is think about
that for 15 seconds to understand that
this is the establishment of boards of
Inquisition that are quasi-judicial that
have an almost unlimited range of uh
what would you say
are they have an almost unlimited range
of arbitrary
judgment and power yeah here's another
one every person who disrupts or
attempts to disrupt the proceedings of a
school or class through the use of
racist language or by engaging in racist
activities now who decides that and
that's that's the Cardinal question is
guilty of an offense and on conviction
is liable to a fine of not more than two
hundred dollars
an anti-racism
is its purpose is to advance racial
equity and racial Equity is the
insistence that every
occupation in every category of position
be distributed through the population in
precise accordance with the percentage
of the people who are
of that group identity in the general
population that's what racial Equity
means it's equality of outcome let's
make no mistake about it has nothing to
do with the equality of opportunity that
Canadians regard as Central to their uh
to their
ideal vision
well I started the very first one there
I mean that great list and you're right
the word Inquisition is is not idly
picked this is the other thing that
should not only worry but it should be
repellent
that there's one segment of the
population or one segment of activists
who have decided that they have the new
decalogue on public virtue particularly
anti-racism which as as a concept
everyone will agree with who wants to be
racist but they aggravate the
circumstance to a tremendous degree and
they arrogate to themselves and now with
the complicity of of the Ontario
government the right to judge and the
right to tell and the right to say what
is right and what is wrong
we have for a hundred years deplored to
Great authoritarian systems of Communism
and Fascism and Nazism where they impose
thoughts the cultural revolution where
if you didn't think and say the right
thing you got beaten with bamboo poles
do the West has never said to any group
of sovereign individuals that once it
has every right thought and the rest of
you if you don't bend to us which is
what this is you don't bend to us you're
a racist you're a messiah the truckers
protest it's a really good one if anyone
now wants to protest what they see as
dangerous in the anti-racism ideology
is that going to be an emergency act too
are there certain sets of illiberal of
liberal thoughts that are so special
that they they completely eviscerate the
entire concept of civil liberties Free
Speech intellectual Challenge and
Authority let me give you a little quote
to understand that this thing is not
isolate and it doesn't come just from
the activist groups it's only back in
last May when Mr Trudeau was talking
about certain things and he was talking
about you know the nature of Canadian
institutions uh I I think I have he was
going on to say that we have in the
building across the way I'm quoting now
for memory I thought I had it written in
the building across the way we have seen
this systemic disadvantages built into
the Canadian political system we are
systemically racist now there's another
another word to pause on for a while
when we stopped and by the way if you
walk out into the city of Toronto you
live here how is it that a systemically
racist country like Canada has its
biggest city and it looks like some some
parade of all the world
how did it come to pass that we who are
so mingy and so close and so
unconsciously and systemically racist in
all our institutions and historically as
Mr Trudeau said
this is one of the most welcoming places
in the world I got smacked across the
face for simply writing that in the
column when the Vietnamese
we were floating on the waves after the
terrible Wars in Vietnam bang most
welcome come in as soon as you can a
smaller episode when the planes went
down on 9 11 and all the passengers
disembarked and Gamble and Gander they
didn't stop to ask him where you were
from or what color you are they took all
into their houses and places we have
allowedness from the leadership down we
have allowed this this thought that if
we Swoon ourselves with self-apology and
we call ourselves bigots and we
apologize for every aspect of a
wonderful Nation this is where all this
stuff comes in from there's the license
and now you've got it in a sophisticated
province of Ontario with a ridiculously
overpriced educational system throwing
out the curriculum and bringing in
Attitude indoctrination based on false
thesis and a very authoritarian
imbalance imagine if you're a teacher
and you see that perhaps the white
students in your class are not receiving
the instruction they should that they're
being degraded because they bear
historical stigma and you say this is
bad for their self-esteem
you can get fired now you can get fired
for doing your job uh I'm I'm remaining
puzzled that an entire caucus and A
legislature in the 21st century most of
whom by the way are educated themselves
allow this thing to dribble in with so
little response and so little common is
like the protest when the banks Froze
all those accounts I haven't heard a
word from any strong opposition where
did you get the authority to do so and
when does government walk into private
citizens accounts because they don't
like what they think this is just
another example of that
so here's another one a performance
appraisal of a teacher shall include
competencies related to a teacher's
anti-racism awareness Okay so
anti-racism awareness okay so now all of
a sudden a teacher is hypothetical
anti-racism awareness whatever that is
is something that's going to be judged
as crucial to their well to the
maintenance of their employment and
their progress through the ranks and so
here's the issue well who's going to
decide that a teacher is sufficiently
anti-racist aware and how are they going
to decide that and by what standards are
they going to judge that and then even
more importantly
who is going to be the judge of that and
why are they in some sort of privileged
position to decide whether or not a
teacher is sufficiently aware uh in this
anti-racist manner and the The Details
Matter in these sorts of things because
competencies are actually
extraordinarily difficult to assess uh
it's taken people a very long time to
build competency assessment in
relationship to literacy and numeracy
for example we do that through objective
testing there are no valid tests there
are no valid and reliable tests that is
measures of something like a teacher's
anti-racism awareness
you that that's the core insult
we can't you you're going to test the
competency of teachers in their
anti-racism build up
in other words uh some agent
is going to determine your moral
competence not just anti-racism when you
get to this kind of Competency testing
what you're saying is I'm going to
decide whether you're a good person or a
bad person now it might be difficult
with the psychological measurements that
you have to to determine competency in
English or mathematics or history it's
difficult but you can get some
reasonable idea of it but if I look at
you
and I decide from a distance and if I'm
also saturated with a particularly
radical perspective and maybe I don't
like you as well why not throw that in
there because it's all subjective here
ah you're not anti-racist enough
I think you should be anti-racist more
where did the possibility of such
questions become a possibility this this
it leaves you almost breathless why are
we willing to assume that expertise in
evaluating someone's anti-racism
awareness even exists I put that at
defeat at large part in in the faculties
of Education who are clueless enough to
be confused about exactly what a
competency means and exactly how that
might be assessed and so and then
there's the punitive elements of this
too so there are disciplinary measures
described within the framework in
response to racism and remember this is
racism that can be unconscious and and
it's very difficult to decide when
exactly that happens
and if and it's racism that's defined as
the absence of an anti-racist Doctrine
as well and so now it can be
punished as well and so then you have to
ask yourself well who are going to flock
to the boards that adjudicate sufficient
racism anti-racism awareness and who's
going to set themselves up as judge and
punishers and the answer is the people
you least want to ever do that and this
is outside of any judicial framework by
the way oh absolutely never do let me
just tell you you've already you already
know this who's going to judge I tell
you who are going to judge the school
awards are going to judge let me give
you a most recent example the biggest
school board in Canada I assume the
Ontario School Board uh the most one of
the most highly private paid students in
Ontario I think are something twelve and
fifteen thousand dollars a student well
let me give you an example of their
Randy races this is specific uh this is
real this is news reporters
there was a young girl
I think she was 12 or 13 at the time in
Afghanistan
all of the things that were going on and
you know all about them anyway she got
captured by ISIS
she was captured as a young girl
she was put into sex slavery she was
passed around you can imagine the
brutalizations of of an orphaned girl in
that circumstance
by some
super supernal effort of will or luck or
both she escapes the damn Camp she
escapes the rape of herself by numerous
Isis figure she then becomes again it's
an amazing story
she becomes a spokesperson for
especially young girls in war conflicts
and in those terrible genuinely terrible
circumstances
and by the time she's 15 or 16 I haven't
got the details precise she wins this
girl who was captured and tortured and
mutilated and raped she wins the Nobel
Prize
this is better than Nelson Mandela
better than Mother Teresa she wins the
Nobel Prize and she becomes a voice an
Afghanistan girl becomes a voice for the
fundamental dignities and liberties
of all young girls everywhere and now we
jump the Toronto School Board had some
sort of Symposium where they would
invite special speakers
and they were lucky enough to receive
the Nobel prize-winning Afghanistan
there's only two or three weeks ago
however the equity Committees of that
little board
they decided that this would not be a
good idea to bring this one into one of
their reading Gatherings because her
presence
her presence might excite islamophobia
when you get into this game of anti this
and anti-that and phobia this and phobia
that and everything is racist
you get to such a ludicrous point
that one of the most spiritually
honorable and physically Brave human
beings is a young girl with a Nobel
Prize and your pure school board says I
don't know if we should bring her in she
might be have a bad influence on our
young people
that's where this is where anti-racism
goes it's it's a different story but
it's the same idea it's the same ethos
and that's what I protest against
the Toronto School awards legislation
right now is just one more installment
of of so many idiocies that have been
coming across such as this male who's
out there now winning every female
swimming championship in the world and
no one wants to stand well very few want
to stand up and say this is absurd and
insulting
so that the higher education quality
Council now will have at least one
member
who shall be a person who has expertise
in racial equity in the post-secondary
education center and so now what we're
being asked to swallow here is the idea
that there is such a thing as expertise
in racial equity in the post-secondary
education sector and so that isn't the
ability to teach kids how to read let's
say or to teach them how to do the
mathematics that will be necessary to
get them through their life but
a new kind of expertise
specifically in the post-secondary
education center that is associated with
the promotion of racial Equity well who
says that that sort of expertise exists
and again who's going to judge its
quality and and the answer is the most
ideologically committed
it is already logically committed it is
the ideologically committed who are
declaring themselves the racial experts
that if you get up and declaim enough
against white history and whiteness and
white fertility and if you throw out
white as a derogatory term if you make
white which is a skin color that at
least in that one category if you make
whiteness a source of evil you're an
expert if you get up and say that I
don't buy this anti-whiteness I I think
human beings are human beings I think
they're personal and spiritual and
family personalities are their kind that
they are not the Constitution just of
their epidermis then you're a racist
here's another big big point before you
bring in these expert anti-racists to
make sure the teachers are okay
what was the purpose of all these
teachers going off to universities and
spending four years for a ba or five or
six for an M.A or even seven for a PhD
to become fully qualified teachers and
then some amateur self-appointed
activists wanders in from some some
Street to have a size up and say oh by
the way you are seven years of this and
you're 10 years of experience in actual
teaching the teaching of subjects that
are in the educational curriculum that
doesn't qualify you here's what's going
to qualify you
if if you are sufficiently genuflective
of my attitudes of my untrained ability
to assess your moral character no one
has the right to judge another person's
soul we've known that for 2 000 years or
more
and when you get down to it you can use
the current terms the anti-racist but
knowledge when people are judging other
people as being insufficiently moral and
inadequately moral to their standards
I mean this is an abandonment of reason
so the anti-racism training referred to
in subsection 5 2 which is the race
anti-racism training that members of the
council will be subject to
shall be trading developed by experts in
the anti-racism education community so
it's the same thing again it's this it's
this insistence that there are experts
in such a thing as anti-racism and that
because of their expertise they're
capable and competent to judge precisely
the moral attitudes of others and then
to find if those others aren't committed
to exactly the same ethical doctrines
that they're committed to because of
their incredible moral standing let's
say that they're to be judged wanting
and not to be promoted as teachers not
to be on Boards of aha this board in
particular was the was the higher
educational higher education quality
Council of Ontario
Etc and so you ask yourself again well
who who would take it upon themselves to
be the judge of such things and also to
claim that they have measurement
instruments that are sufficiently
sophisticated to assess even unconscious
racial bias
um maybe even the unconscious racial
bias that people are striving to
overcome to the degree that it exists
so
it's obsessional uh again we we're in a
period
uh we have been for 10 15 20 years in
which these I'll call them this these
ancillary concerns there was a period in
human history and not very long ago
when you had the extremes
the absolute extremes of bigotry there
were periods the Irish we can go all
through and go back 2 000 years but no
one wants to admit and this is what I
find personally puzzling that let's say
our own country Canada
uh whatever the flaws and flaws and they
were many and they were deep
but do you honestly believe that the
general attitude of the Canadian
population in 2021 on these various
particular topics is not an immense
improvement over the historical
standards of go back 50 100 200 200
there has been a great emergence we have
had programs now for 30 years of
affirmative action we have had apologies
that were put out by the entire
legislature of Canada itself we have had
self-scrutiny we have had commissions
and we have made racism real racism okay
we've made that one of the most Savage
taboos that we know
60 years ago you could make jokes about
Jews and get laughed at in all the
comedy centers of the world
you wouldn't do it now and you certainly
won't do it about blacks and you will
not do it about ethnic Canadians either
because hey we don't like the roughness
of it we don't like the implicit kind of
snark
but in the majority of cases I insist on
this the majority of ordinary Canadian
citizens
are explicitly explicitly welcoming of
others of those who are different and
they will help they will help at the
slightest impulse as I said 9 11 1 the
great boat to Tillis from Vietnam
we've turned this on its head all the
efforts to upgrade our moral sensibility
which a lot of Canadians have done over
the generations everyone is a product of
their time
but why do people from 50 or 60
countries come to Canada if it is as Mr
Trudeau again understand that the
leadership taking this point really
licenses these kinds of activities goes
on about being systemically racist and
genocidal the attitude of the ordinary
major Canadian who is not into some
professional anti-activist bunch
I'd like to help if you're in trouble I
will help you I am not looking at the
color of your face to determine whether
you're good or you're bad and by the way
this also goes two layers you're not
looking at the color of mine to say well
if you're white uh not only morally
deficit you must be put into some sort
of training class listen we keep saying
we're not China
but on the softer elements of it
cultural revolution thought control
my question back to you for that last
list you just gave me
where does the competence come to in
those who are assuming to judge the left
has a certain tendency to assume and to
get accepted as assuming that they have
infallibility because they scream about
moral wrongs the hypocrisies that go on
there take the environmental movement
are immense and somehow rather an entire
government
listens to this this this
imported and pernicious philosophy and
now allows it to dominate the entire
curriculum of a province and past
judgment on its teachers and bring it
outside and its parents it's well again
some parents I've I've had before I even
had any contact with you I've had
notices over the summer of some of the
bulletins coming out of Halton and
Ontario they're always about either
sexual uh training induction into the
great transgender list let me tell you
there's a school in England that I read
about just two or three days ago it is
one of the most expensive private
schools in all of England it's close to
fifty thousand dollars a student
and parents learned only fifty thousand
dollars a student the parents learn
among other things that they were into
the new gender Equity is equity pops up
yet again
and in that school and this is not a
joke this is reported in his print
they were teaching that there were 62
genders
now I don't know how the educated mind
can allow itself to slip to such such
ape-like incompetence that at fifty
thousand dollars a year a student must
accept the thesis that there are 62
human genders you think that's just a
particular example of no it isn't it's a
symbolic example it's the same thing
with the CRT in in Ontario schools look
schools teach
I don't know what it is about these
ancillary causes that they blot out on
back where I began that they blot out
the purpose of Education that in many
cases because it's indoctrination they
nullify it we need better schools and we
need better instruction in the
disciplines that schools are supposed to
be teaching they can't always be
elevating the ancillary and the trendy
and the fashionable and the hard left as
a replacement
for the millennial old purposes of real
education and as you know you know
better it's the damn universities that
set this tidal Motion in progress with
the with again the nursery of all these
these ridiculous theories and their
microaggressions and and their safety
Concepts and I can't have a speaker in
here because it'll traumatize me the
triviality that the universities anyway
all this language surrounding group
identity yeah and the language of
Oppression was formulated in the
universities and taught and not least in
the faculties of education and then
disseminated into the broader public
through
um the news media organizations that
hired graduates of those institutions
there's been recent documentation of
that and anyone who thinks that the
relationship between the races and the
ethnicities and the Sexes has been
improved by all the recent dialogue has
a different thing coming here's another
one that's quite fun if the minister
learns upon conducting an investigation
or or otherwise that a member of the
council so this is the higher education
quality Council of Ontario again that a
member does not have a proven commitment
to racial equity in the post-secondary
education sector the minister shall
require that member to take anti-racism
training within the following six months
so now
indoctrination becomes a mandate
willingness to submit to uh
indoctrination by anti-racism experts
has become a criteria for serving on
this Council
I wonder what would happen you know go
back 15 years ago if say a Catholic
School of order a Pentecostal School
award for that but it doesn't really
matter
if they said to all the teachers coming
in you know I got to check you on the
doctrines here are you a good believer
in transubstantiation uh you stand by
the sacrament of extra monks shouldn't
you have any core any queries about the
Trinity perhaps uh we insist uh you know
you give us evidence and proof of this
and if you don't we're going to get rid
of you uh where did this streak of
Investigations and and inquire
inquisitions where is it
do we not have it well it's like after
the emergency act I don't know anymore
we used to think we had a Charter of
Rights and Freedoms
this this thing is it's a bulldozer on
speed going through all of them it's
also a Defiance going back to the
competence and integrity of the majority
you don't have to prove
you're not a racist this is this is
negatively negative investigation you
can't prove a negative to begin with but
they're going to set up they're going to
give authority to and they're going to
allow them to occupy this is my biggest
thing they're going to occupy the
curriculum if you're doing this you're
not doing that
and instead of applauding and cheering
young people you know the person makes a
great drawing or plays a new piece of
music or has a fine sentence and the
teacher comes down all smiles and
genuine enthusiasm hey my God Maggie you
have done so well
only now it's oh uh is she looking the
wrong way at the wrong person is my
fellow teacher over there is is she
subconsciously racist and doesn't want
to hear about it uh am I up to date on
what is the latest Dogma from CRT no
it's the subjects they're supposed to be
in love with it's the students they're
supposed to be inspiring it isn't to sit
there as agents of some some as I said
hard left arid desiccated angry little
Doctrine here's the bureaucracy that's
going to be produced every college or
university shall collect from its
students faculty staff and other persons
whatever that means and provide to the
minister such data and other information
related to the following as may be
requested by the minister
the number of times Support Services
complaints resolutions and accommodation
relating to racism are requested made
and obtained by students enrolled at or
faculty or staff of the college or
university and information about those
supports any anti-racism initiatives and
programs established by the college
University to promote awareness of the
supports and services
the number of incidents and complaints
of racism reported by students faculty
and staff and information about how such
incidents incidents and complaints
including
how the incidents and complaints were
addressed or resolved the implementation
and effectiveness of the policy so that
means every and that's not just for
colleges and universities if I have read
this correctly it's throughout the
education system as a whole so that
means the establishment of a bureaucracy
that is devoted to doing nothing but
Gathering such data and Reporting it and
so all you have to do is think for about
15 seconds to imagine what that's going
to mean because systems tilt themselves
to produce what is being measured
exactly so but again it's where are they
going with this I mean this is again
it's it's it is from the authoritarian
regimes you check on thought you check
on the number of complaints and by the
way if you start to invite complaints on
a truly hot subject it can get very
personal very quickly there's people in
the various jobs teaching broadcasting
business anywhere else else if you set
up an investigative structure and a
reported structure and a tabulation
structure if I want to do damage to you
and if I pick the right side of this
particular context I'm going to move you
out we cannot we cannot allow the
bureaucratization
of the search into people's attitudes
and souls to become a legislative
possibility uh you know I I get
legislative necessity yeah this is let
me give you one other thing this is a
proof of what I just said this is a very
high high standard proof this is Great
Britain itself I'm just going to redo
the headlines again it's a story it's
print it's real
their race oversight his name was Tony
Sewell and he wrote a report he was
appointed by Boris Johnson this is not
you know some freelancer uh and uh he
founded Britain and there's again like
we met Trudeau would systemically race
he found by the way he's black but
shouldn't matter but these days we have
to say it he found that Britain was not
institutionally racist and an and blast
Northland ham University cowards for
withdrawing his university honorary
degree he was given a degree in 2019 but
they withdrew it after a study that was
commissioned by him objective in nature
Pro not proving certainly asserting that
Britain was not institutionally racist
and they said this was done to him
because he was the subject of political
controversy well let me give you a
translation of that the accepted idea
among the woke classes that were all now
a bunch of racists homophobes
islamophobes transfer name default
arachnophobe that has to be accepted as
absolute law however if a person from
even one of those groups this is again
the racists are of Great Britain
appointed by Tony I'm Sorry by by Morris
and he reports after doing an objective
survey and he himself a black person no
we're not universally racist and then
all the correct thoughts stars and the
university types and the politicians and
most of the newspapers dump him he's
thrown out the same thing happened to
Roland fryer in Harvard University who
did a statistical study of of shootings
by police officers and found that more
whites proportionately were shot than
blacks he had won the world's top
economics prize as a young black man
and yet he got nailed on a sexual
harassment idea but the real provocation
behind it was because he reported some
good news
on the so-called racial front good news
is now bad news good news is racist in
itself there's two people high stature
high qualifications both black both
ostracized because they spoke a clear
truth against these doctrines so where
are we Jordan's my question I don't know
anymore maybe we'll maybe we'll close by
just reviewing this last section so this
is in schools in general and uh one of
the subsection alterations here is not
that the minister May establish that's
re that's replaced with the wording the
minister shall establish so this now
becomes a requirement that
policies and guidelines have to be put
in place
with respect to promoting racial equity
in schools which must include policies
and guidelines respecting training in
this racial Equity Doctrine for all
teachers and other staff resources to
support people's teachers and staff who
have been targeted by racism strategies
to support pupils teachers and staff who
Witness
incidents of racism resources to support
them who have engaged in racist
behaviors procedures this is really a
terrible one procedures that allow
pupils teachers and staff to report
incidents of racism safely and in a way
that minimizes the possibility of
reprisal so there goes facing your
accuser and there goes the presumption
of innocence and that necessitates the
establishment of quasi-judicial boards
of Inquisition
the use of disciplinary measures within
the framework in response to racism
etc
etc the details that you've outlined
here and again you've done a closer read
but these are now it sounds rhetorical
but it isn't
these are horrifying
we don't let other people judge other
people and we don't bring in the crowd
of self-dedicated
uni-dimensional predetermined Minds on
some particular cause then to become
Judiciary investigator Punisher
publisher
of other people and we're also building
the whole idea of an anti-racism
curriculum that is this deep and this
obsessional
is that you are acceding to the to the
thought
that the thousands and thousands of
Ontario teachers
are morally deficit
they're morally we that we have been
running a system here and until we get
these these these new angels of racial
Purity and start teaching them all about
bias and oppression and everything else
that the bunch running in our schools
are either uneducated or bigots but
again obviously here's the thing that
more than it I gotta keep saying it once
you make obsessional and pervasive and
saturated the concept the critical
racial Theory and make that the soul of
the educational effort
you have displaced the educational
effort you are cheating young people you
are cheating their parents you are lying
to them I would much I would like to see
you just one month that eight or nine
Ontario School boards put out something
not racist not about sex not about
transgender not about environmentalism
but about a damn subject in their
schools and how it's bidding better when
was the last time
that the educational authorities of this
province started firing a bulletins
saying boy are we are we teaching better
than we've ever taught before our
students are alive with the hunger for
knowledge and they are ecstatic when
they find new adventures in thought
their minds are growing their characters
are stronger they love their country
house that is another one to throw in
there and where instead of this is this
alien
perverse angry useless Doctrine becoming
the central the Cardinal impulse and
dynamic of a modern educational system
it is terrible
well Rex I think that's probably a good
note on which to end this rather
pessimistic discussion yeah the
conservatives and the Liberals that the
small L liberal types Canadians in
general parents in Ontario and in Canada
take the time to actually read through
this bill and think about it and then to
try to ask themselves how in the world
we got to this place that's the big
question how do we get here how do we
get out of it
Jordan thank you very much for your time
thanks for your time Rex
[Music]